in the video on the autoionization of
water we saw that you could have two
neutral water molecules but one of them
could swipe a hydrogen ion from the
other and then you could be left with a
hydronium ion and the one that had the
hydro the hydrogen ion swipe from it
remember a hydrogen ion is really just a
proton this one actually gains an
electron it gains an electron from that
hydrogen it takes it takes the elect all
the electrons from this covalent bond
right over here and it forms another
lone pair and it gets a negative charge
and that becomes a hydroxide ion or we
could also describe that autoionization
like this that if i have one water
molecule well the the the oxygen it
grabs both of the electrons from this
lone pair swipes hydrogen of the one
electron it had and all of it's all it's
left with is its proton so a hydrogen
ion is often
it's really just talking about a proton
because the most common isotope of
hydrogen only has a proton in its
nucleus it does not have a neutron so
you take away its electron you just have
that proton left and the whole point of
doing this to show look it could it
could it's not going to be a typical
thing most of the water molecules aren't
going to be doing this but this this is
going to happen if you have a large
enough quantity of water molecules and
we've even seen to what degree that
happens how typical that is by looking
at the concentration if we looked at the
concentration so if we're talking about
pure
water
we've seen that the concentration and we
could think about it in two ways if we
think about this top way of expressing
the autoionization we could say the
concentration of hydronium ions
or if we think about this one over here
we could think about the concentration
of hydrogen ions and the reason why
these two things are equivalent is
because these hydrogen ions are really
just going to associate themselves with
a water molecule and become hydronium
but in pure water at 25 degrees celsius
we've seen that these are going to be
approximately the concentration whether
you think of it as hydronium
concentration or hydrogen ion
concentration
it's going to be approximately 1 times
10 to the negative 7
molar and what does that mean well molar
this is just units for molarity that's
the same thing as 1 times 10 to the
negative 7
moles
moles per liter and if you have trouble
remembering what moles are first of all
i encourage you to watch that video on
khan academy on moles but you have to
remind ourselves it's a quantity just as
a dozen means 12 of something a mole of
something means 6.022 times and roughly
6.022 times 10 to the 23rd of that thing
so it's just a very very very large
quantity so that's the concentration you
could say the hydrogen ion concentration
in pure water at 25 degrees celsius but
we could have ask ourselves that same
question for other for other types of
solutions
for example orange juice so let's just
say right over here so an orange juice
orange juice
the hydrogen ion concentration and once
again i could also say this is a
hydronium concentration depending on
your glass of orange juice it wouldn't
be atypical to find a glass that has a
hydrogen ion concentration of say
1 times 10 to the negative 3.5
molar so once again this is this is
actually a lot more than this here
actually let me make it a round number
you actually might be able to find
something at 10 times 1 times 10 to the
negative 4 molar i looked it up on the
on the internet there's a there's
actually a range kind of in the mid 3s
to low 4s of hydrogen ion concentrations
for orange juice and so you could find
something like this and as you can tell
it's good to always just think about the
numbers this is actually a much higher
concentration than this over here the
exponent over here is less negative so
this is a higher concentration so this
is a higher concentration
a higher concentration and we could look
at something that has a lower
concentration say something like bleach
i actually looked up so bleach i'll
write that right over here
i actually looked it up on the clorox
website the clorox bleach they say that
their hydrogen ion concentration is
approximately so their hydrogen ion
concentration is approximately equal to
equal to 1 times 10 to the negative 12
1 times 10 to the negative 12 molar so
this is a much lower concentration than
you would have in just in just water
right over in pure water 25 degrees
celsius so this is a much lower
concentration this exponent over here is
more negative this is a lower
concentration
well this is all well and good but it
can get a little bulky talking about
concentrations in terms of you know
scientific notation something times
something to the negative whatever molar
and so to help simplify that people have
invented the idea of a ph
aph and let me introduce it in a color
that i have not used yet before p
and you use lowercase p uppercase h and
i've looked into where this this this
notation comes from the h most people
agree is referring to the hydrogen in
some way but the p some people think
it's referring to potential some people
just think it's a random letter that was
it's just one of these historical
artifacts but this is defined as the
negative log
of and we could say negative log if we
if we don't write a base you assume it's
base 10 but the negative log of the
hydrogen ion concentration or it's
equivalently the negative log because
every the hydrogen ions are really
hydronium ions h3o it's really the same
thing as this as well
so given this
given this definition of ph let's
calculate the phs for pure water at 25
degrees celsius so the pure the ph of
this glass of orange juice so the ph of
this bleach
well the ph of this pure water is going
to be
the ph
let me see let me do it in the so the ph
here
so i'll have some space right over here
it's going to be the negative log and
i'll write the base 10 there just
because that's assumed of its hydrogen
ion concentration which is 1 times 10 to
the negative 7 molar and we want
molarity right over here you want
molarity right over here well 1 times 10
the negative 7 is the same thing as 10
to the negative 7
and if you look at if you look at just
the part with a logarithm before we
think about the negative this is just
saying to what power do we have to raise
10 to get 10 to the negative 7th power
well that's just going to be negative
seven and if what i just did is
confusing i encourage you to review
logarithms on khan academy so we're
gonna have the negative of negative
seven which is going to be equal to
which is going to be equal to positive
seven so the ph of pure water at 25
degrees celsius and temperature would
matter because it might affect the
autoionization it but the ph at 25
degrees celsius is 7. what about this
orange juice well the ph
the ph over here is going to be the
negative log of instead of writing 1
times 10 to the negative 4 i can just
write 10 to the negative 4.
and of course that's base 10.
well what do i have to raise 10 to to
get 10 to the negative 4 we'll have to
raise that to the negative 4 power the
negative of negative 4 is positive 4.
by that same argument or by applying the
same definition the ph the ph of this
bleach is going to be equal to the
negative log of 10 to the negative 12.
i'm just ignoring this one times right
over here i could write 1 times 10 to
the negative 12 but that's not going to
change its value and that of course is
going to be equal to the negative of
negative 12 which is positive which is
positive 12. and so it might be fun to
plot all of these so let me do that so
let me plot these ph's
let me plot these ph's so
let me draw a
line right over here
and let's say that this is
4. actually i'm not going to be able to
get all the way to 12 so i have to make
that a little my scale a little bit
smaller 0
1 2
5 6
9 10 11 12 and i could keep i could keep
going over here so let me write this one
two three four five six
seven eight
nine 10
11 12. so this is these are our ph's
over here i could plot them that water
at 25 degrees celsius is going to be
right over here
and that is my water and that's
sometimes referred to as a neutral ph if
i look at that orange juice with a ph of
4 that orange juice is going to be right
over here and i've seen ranges for
orange juices actually more in this
range right over here so depending on
your glass or whether it's gone bad or
not so that's going to be orange juice
could be found in that range so i'll
write
orange juice
orange
juice and then this bleach
it and it depends on the concentration
and all of that but this bleach in
particular is right over here
this bleach is right over here and i can
plot other things if your your stomach
the the juices in your stomach are
highly highly well i'll use i'll talk
about the acidic a little bit more but
your stomach juices are
are going to be
are going to be in let me just say a new
color are going to be in this range are
going to be in this range right over
here so stomach
stomach and often recalled you know
instead of stomach juice is stomach
acid
and if you had something like sea water
it is it is going to be it's going to be
in this range
in this range right over here seawater
now let's think about what this what
this is telling us remember this is a
logarithmic scale if we as we go to the
right as we go to
the right
our concentration
is going down it's important to
recognize and that's all because of this
negative right over here in our
definition but we saw that bleach has a
much lower concentration than the water
has so this is lower
lower hydrogen
ion concentration and as we go to the
left we have a higher hydrogen ion
concentration higher hydrogen ion
concentration and in general if
something has a ph below 7 we we tend to
refer to it as acidic
we say it is
acidic so typically when you add acids
to neutral water it's going your ph is
going to go down it's going to get more
and more acidic and as you go to the
right if you have a ph above 7 sometimes
you'll hear people say basic
and sometimes you also might hear people
say alkaline
alkaline it is becoming more alkaline
its hydrogen concentration is getting
lower and lower and lower as we move to
the right
and i really want you to appreciate the
logarithmic nature of it because if i
handed you some sea water with a ph of
8. you might say okay no big deal ph of
8 relative to a ph of 7. but that's
actually this is a logarithmic scale if
we're moving to the right we have 10
times
we have a 10 times lower concentration
of hydrogen ions if we were to move if
we were to move three spaces to the
right on this whereas this it's
one-tenth one-tenth one-tenth we have
one thousandth the concentration of
hydrogen ions so it's pretty and it's
pretty interesting to think about the
how how low how much lower the hydrogen
concentration is in say bleach than in
water and how much lower that is than
say stomach acid or orange juice